we have a very very exciting episode of
hatred mail this week if you've never
heard hatred mail before it's when a
professional voice-over artist narrates
the hate mail that I get here's a little
bit of a preview as to what we mean when
we talk about hatred mail because it's
time to make America hate again Patriot
mail written by Patriots who hate David
Pakman because America and because
freedom yeah so this week's hatred mail
asks what is it I know it this is a
question that has been on the minds of a
lot of people in the audience and that
question is is of are you cocked that is
a it's it's such a question central to
the future of humanity sure that that's
the question asked by this week's hater
email that's it
I'm unsubscribing from this David Pakman
guy M so sick of he attacking our
president and never reporting about how
the great economy is doing under Trump
you moon bats are something else a
genuine question when is it appropriate
to and is of are you cut David fake
Pakman show David should resign off of
YouTube and you imagine if I did a
YouTube resignation you know nothing
would happen like it would be completely
uneventful in every way is of are you
cooked
that's the question someday I hope we
get an answer it reminds me of like
insofar as yeah in and of itself I don't
know what they but it doesn't make any
sense it makes no sense whatsoever but
what does make sense is giving the
middle finger to the hey tree its you
can use the coupon code hey tree at 40
when you go to david pakman.com slash
membership and you go to sign up and no
matter which membership you select you
type in hey tree at 40 that saves you 40
percent off your membership and it's a
way to turn hey tree at ism into
something very very good for independent
media that coupon code is spelled h atri
OT 4-0